so it can actually be a little bit
confusing if you're trying to redeem
your playstation plus games through the
official playstation app so here you
have the first page that you come to and
this is on iphone i assume android looks
pretty close to this this of course is
my recently played game so yours is
going to look different but where you
need to go is you need to look down all
the way at the bottom and right in the
middle you'll see the icon for the
playstation store it looks like a little
bag so you go ahead and tap on that from
there you scroll all the way to the
bottom of this page and it's kind of
like wait where's the playstation plus
you think maybe i press on free to play
no you're going to look for that tiny
little arrow right there at the bottom
tap that and then here at the bottom
left you'll see playstation plus tap
that you're almost there now right here
in the middle of the screen you'll see
where you can redeem the monthly games
i'm going to go ahead and redeem over
cook 2 here you just tap on it and then
you press add to library and that is how
you do it all straight from the
playstation app